so I have finished the kitchen I
finished my bedroom I finished the
office and I'm just wrapping up the
living room okay I'll get pack a Lacan I
love it I love it mind if I put on some
music
I do not all right you're not I got this
new dubstep what is that I know what
that is oh dude you're gonna love it
oh cool cool man I'm sorry
[Music]
[Music]
Oh what is that
the music I'm sorry is that music oh
yeah dude that's the dubstep man that's
my jam well as it's a little loud and
disorienting and you know you're being a
little rough with my things
rough with it dude your stuff is fine
why am i sweating so much because you're
feeling it is that a good thing
yes come on man give me another shot
okay okay I will
[Music]
[Music]
dude you totally jacking my flow your
nose is bleeding and so is mine
oh it doesn't really seem like music to
me okay
Wow Wally getting a little bit old No
all right do that come on no didn't
realize that okay um yeah what would you
rather listen to I can hook you up with
some Hootie on the Blowfish if that's
your oh that's funny
it's that good Color Me badd you know
what go ahead I don't care I see what
you're doing go ahead and play it I
don't care because I'm not that old I
can get into it okay
we just let's just get this stuff packed
play
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can peel all-new episodes Wednesdays at
10:30 on Comedy Central
[Music]